لدي سؤال ، لدي سؤال
لك ، تريد أن تقول أنك لا تريد
الرياضيين البيلاروسيين والروس في دورة
الألعاب الأولمبية ، آسف لأنني كنت أطرح
سؤالاً على الوزيرة ، إنها
وزيرة الرياضة التي أسألها أنها لا تريدها '
نريد أن يشارك الرياضيون الروس أو الروس
في الألعاب الأولمبية الدولية
أو الأحداث الرياضية ، لكن هل شعرت
بنفس الطريقة بعد غزو الولايات المتحدة للعراق ،
وماذا عن أفغانستان وماذا عن كندا
وماذا عن القوات الكندية بعد أن
قصفنا رياضيين البقان بعد قصفنا
أه ليبيا أو
عذر أفغانستان  لماذا لا تجيب على
السؤال ، إنه سؤال بسيط حقًا
أرسله الوزير ، إنه
سؤال بسيط حقًا لماذا ماذا عن
الرياضيين الإسرائيليين ، احتلال إسرائيل لمدة
50 عامًا لأراضي فلسطين
في دولة الفصل العنصري ،
ماذا عن الحظر  الرياضيون الإسرائيليون
شكرا لكم